- Mold, hair, poop,
things you'd never allow yourself to eat.
But according to the FDA,
you've probably been
eating them for years.
The United States Food
and Drug Administration
has identified levels
of 179 natural or
unavoidable defects in food
that are an acceptable
risk to your health.
Let's take a look at the shocking things
that the FDA allows on your plate.
Peewoop.
The FDA's Food Defect Levels Handbook
lists insect parts as the most
common defect in your food.
We're talking legs, wings,
thoraxes, whole heads and brains.
These insects show up
in your frozen fruit,
frozen broccoli, frozen Brussels sprouts.
Odds are, anything that
grows out of the soil
probably has some degree of insect parts
that accidentally get taken in
when the plants get harvested.
In the case of items like cinnamon
that get ground into a powder,
the insects can get ground in there too.
And while eating those insects
might not sound too appetizing,
remember, the FDA deems
it poses no inherent
hazard to your health.
It could potentially give you
a little protein kick too.
The second most common
defect in American food
is mold, rot and mildew.
And if you've ever let
fruits or vegetables
sit too long on the
table or in the fridge,
then you know mold is inevitable,
and is pretty easy to notice.
Blue cheese, good mold.
Shiitake mushrooms,
technically, good mold too.
But some mold is quite dangerous
and can actually produce mycotoxins.
Unfortunately, mold is common
in something you may consume every day.
Coffee beans.
Don't panic though.
In order to pass the
inspection by the FDA,
no more than 10% of beans in
any given count can be moldy.
And there's an important note here.
While small amounts of mold
in foods monitored by the FDA is okay,
you should never eat a piece of bread
with even a small spot of mold on it.
While you may think mold exists
in just that discoloration,
the microscopic roots of that mold
spread throughout the entire item.
This is unlike berries,
where you can throw away the
berry with the visible mold
and consume the other
normal appearing ones.
(lips smacking)
Oh, I got bear hair in my mouth.
And speaking of bear hairs,
rodent hair is the third most
common defect in our food.
It shows up commonly in ground spices
like cinnamon, curry, oregano and nutmeg,
but also in items like
macaroni and cheese,
peanut butter and popcorn.
Literally, the FDA says one rodent hair
per hundred grams of
peanut butter is A-okay.
I think if you have a pet like I do,
we definitely consume
more hairs than that.
Right, Bear?
High five.
(Dr. Mike chuckles)
Probably the fanciest name on the list,
Mammalia excreta is the
fourth most common defect.
Despite its Latin name,
Mammalia excreta is not
some high-end perfume
or university catchphrase.
It's poop, animal poop.
Where there are animals, there is poop.
And you've most likely been eating it.
I'm talking black pepper,
cocoa beans, even wheat.
I understand that eating Mammalian excreta
is probably the most disgusting
thing you could think of,
but just remember that manure or cow poop
is used to grow crops
all around the world.
So say it with me, "we all
poop" and "thank you, poop."
This next one isn't even so bad.
Foreign matter.
This is a random collection
of all sorts of weird little things
that can slip into the growth, harvesting,
and shipping process.
Things like sticks from
plants, stones from the earth,
burlap bag material from
transport, and cigarette butts.
The FDA only allows up to 1%
of the weight of pickings
and siftings of these foods
to contain foreign matter though.
So it's really nothing you
should concern yourself about.
How about a tasty bowl of babies?
That's right.
The FDA recognizes that it's financially
and realistically impossible
to completely eliminate
insect eggs, larvae, and
maggots from your food.
That's why they allow up to five fly eggs
per 500 grams of canned tomatoes,
two 3 millimeter long
larvae in canned corn,
or 10 insect eggs per 8 ounces of raisins.
And I only thought people
ate larvae on "Fear Factor."
We are so grateful to
mother earth for our food
so we shouldn't be too ungrateful
to learn that she's left a
bit more of herself in there
than meets the eye.
The FDA allows a small
amount of shells, stems,
sand, and pits in our food.
You'll find pits in
dates, olives and prunes,
shells with your nuts,
stems in your cloves,
and sand in your cumin.
Again, all very small amounts.
There's probably some good
fiber in there anyway.
And finally, it's time for what I think
is the most disgusting defect
the FDA allows in our food,
parasitic cysts.
It sounds gross when I even say it.
A cyst is a sac that could be filled
with air, liquid, pus, or parasites.
A parasitic cyst is a sac
that contains the larvae,
or the baby version of a parasite.
Consumption of undercooked meats and fish
puts you at a higher risk
for developing parasitic infections
like worms in your GI tract.
Complete prevention of
parasitic cysts from fish
is impractical, as they're
frequently found inside the fish,
and therefore, some of those cysts
inevitably wind up in our seafood.
For example, in white fish,
the FDA allows up to 50 parasitic
cysts per hundred pounds.
That's why I recommend you
err on the side of caution
and skip that gas station sushi.
Lots of people ask me if it's
dangerous to hold in a sneeze,
I answer that question here,
and more on this responding to comments.
Check it out.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
And be careful with those sneezes.
Watch that video.
(inhales) Just kidding. Gotcha.
(bright music)